Pictures for things and even ideas gave
us prodo riding, but we can do better.
It's time to invent full fledged writing.
You're ready to grab that Chisel and
get your pictographic and idiographic
carving on then someone
inventive comes along.
You system is artistic,
but it's not practical enough for her.
Gone are the days of Lascaux the
world outside. This cave is changing.
She says crops, cities, rulers, markets,
and she needs a way to keep track
of it all. She likes your icons.
She can use them for goats and Potts
fields and even long walks through the
desert, but she has an
incredible practical streak.
She takes those goats in those
pots and starts to tally the items.
She's recording one goat.
She says. Then two goats,
three goats for goats.
Notice what she's done.
These aren't simple depictions anymore.
They're not just ideas.
She's reading one word for each symbol.
She's in coding language.
Let's slow down here because it's hard
to overstate the importance of this major
moment in the history of writing
these goat counts or words,
symbols. Now, Loga graphs.
Pictographs can be visualized. Idiot.
Graphs can be imagined,
but loga graphs can be directly and
consistently red logo graphics systems
emerge and flourish. And
the early civilizations of
Mesopotamia, Egypt, China,
and Mexico, characters for
people, animals, land crops,
hundreds, even thousands of logo graphs
for everything under the sun and moon,
including the sun and the moon.
Even after all these millennia,
if you spent hard enough,
you can still pick out the symbol,
scratching to weathered artifacts,
bearing the world's early scripts,
a Chinese turtle and Egyptian house,
a Sumerian head,
a Sumerian had eating bread. Oh my. And
Jaguar. And in each of these places,
in all of these languages,
these were red as words.
We know what these lower graphs mean
and we can put that meaning into words.
The world is now in a race to
fill itself with logo graphs.
But which humans started this craze?
Well,
the Mesoamericans started writing
more than 2,900 years ago.
Some Chinese characters,
or at least 3,200 years old writing
popped up in Crete 4,000 years ago.
But the two clear contenders are Egyptian
hieroglyphs and Sumerian cuneiform.
Both a whopping 5,000 years old minimum.
It's common to say that the Egyptian
stole the idea of writing from Mesopotamia
and just came up with their own glyphs.
Common but not demonstrated for a while.
Mana genesis made sense.
This is the idea that one civilization
was king of all the writing.
That writing started once in Mesopotamia,
where people pressed a stylist in
a wet clay to make these wedge.
Cutaneous shapes,
forms cuneiform,
so the Mana Genesis story goes,
everyone else steals cuneiform
and re it to fit their own needs.
It's not a popular story these days.
Given what we know about Chinese and
especially Mesoamerican writing along with
some very early Egyptian fines,
whoever's first in these early days
of writing all the civilizations start
manufacturing hordes of logo graphs.
So many in fact,
that they unwittingly unleash an epic
memory burden on budding locog refers from
would be ancient scribes to beginning
students of Mandarin Chinese.
Do they really need this many characters
to write? Surely there's an easier way.